my phone smells I want a new one
I'm not satisfied I paid for his cell
phone I'll get the manager out to smell
your phone I'm actually very curious to
see what happens here we broke up when I
was gonna tell you tomorrow so you need
to leave right now I just lost my job
now you're gonna dump me
what happened I'm having some work done
on my apartment well what about a hotel
geez mom I never asked you for anything
this could be our last chance to bond
you always said she was the one it's
over
we're great together me or not great
together
don't touch that my sticks I'll touch
them she was one of the ones yes but now
I need another one don't you just hate
these things
excuse me I bet she's nagged the life
out of him yeah I hear you only 36
really yeah they're my grandparents
Jimmy my situation how have I never seen
her before
dude you got hook it up what do you
thought sure the Grinch that stole
Christmas I'm totally into yoga yeah I
love it
[Music]
sweat lodge I really want to go let's go
sweat lodge sounds fun I'm suffocating
you
oh you went to Harvard yes I did yes I
actually read now
miss dr. Reynolds to learn he was the
best he was a shoe so you lied to me
about everything no I was memorable
honest in my life than while I was lying
about although
[Music]
you